el apoyo se siente de donald trump y
rodríguez se alista para escuchar al
presidente trauma en orlando la ciudad
de florida que lo acogió tras emigrar de
puerto rico hace dos décadas este
ferviente simpatizante republicano
asegura que el mandatario estadounidense
ha hecho más por la comunidad pública
que ningún otro el presidente de trump
no han dado asignaciones millonarias
para ayudar a la red a la reconstrucción
de las ciudades más afectadas por los
temblores y por los abates de maría y de
los otros huracanes
el huracán maría en 2017 obligó a llamar
a abandonar la isla para el drama
olvidado esta comunidad que aún hoy
sigue sufriendo los estragos del ciclón
los boricuas que residen en puerto rico
no pueden participar en las elecciones
presidenciales pero el que vive en
florida si puede y lo hará por el cambio
el 3 de noviembre que hayan ayuda para
nosotros los latinos por ejemplo los
puertorriqueños como yo queremos
que se nos ayude como ciudadanos
americanos no que nos traten como si no
fuéramos ciudadanos americanos
como yo mar 135.000 llegaron al área de
orlando después del huracán maría la
ciudad cuenta con la mayor población
boricua de todo el país los que llegaron
estaban indignados contra amp pero
agradecidos por la gestión del gobierno
estatal que es republicano muchos ya han
regresado a la isla y el impacto de los
nuevos votantes es incierto
históricamente los votantes
puertorriqueños han votado el 60% por
los demócratas el 40% por los
republicanos a ambas facciones en este
momento están muy entusiasmadas
en un estado pendular como florida que
se ha vuelto el foco de atención en
estas elecciones cada voto cuenta las
encuestas no dan un claro vencedor y la
diferencia estaría en unos pocos votos
que podrían ser los de los
puertorriqueños